le système médiatique est d'une pauvreté
absolue c'est le moment qui les
intéresse là on va bouffer de la reine
d'Angleterre pendant 10 jours une phrase
qui a choqué de nombreuses personnes
faut quand même bien choisir les mots on
va bouffer de la reine d'Angleterre
je trouve ça même extrêmement chiant et
vous êtes-vous choqué par les propos de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pas question tiens j'aimerais bien avoir
la vie de des téléspectateurs
franchement il a plein qui sont pas
choqués
toi tu es choqué vraiment moi je suis
choqué ça la semaine dernière on était à
la maison tu m'as dit que j'ai terminé
le lendemain j'ai dit ça ça y est
surtout que les chaînes info on part de
la reine et dans la rue dans les
bistrots on ne parle pas de la reine les
gens on dit c'est bon ça arrêtez de nous
saouler avec la reine sauf que lui c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors politique il
peut pas employer des termes comme ça
c'est pour se rapprocher des gens qui
faisait il faut dire ce que pensent les
Français
il peut penser exactement ce qu'il pense
il aurait fallu penser mais le formuler
différemment moi c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'aime pour ça arrêtez si on
l'aime pas pour arrêter c'est où il est
il parle comme il parle comme ça voilà
qu'on dit ça de lui s'il arrive si lui
arrive
bon c'est bon
tu trouves ça drôle bah je trouve ça
drôle
[Applaudissements]
parce que on a pas du tout eu de
débordements
on la voit trop on ne cesse de faire des
plateaux d'info en permanence c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup trop ok mais il
faut savoir partir ça fait du sel ça
fait du sport
je vous donne simplement un chiffre
est-ce que vous savez que normalement
Paris Match il tire à 500 000 exemples
toi tu tires à combien de temps
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous savez là dire le nombre
d'exemplaires qui a été déposé en Kia
combien ils espèrent vendre à 1 million
3 donc il y a aussi un côté
il va y avoir encore
ce que je veux dire c'est que d'un point
de vue pressant en tout cas Elisabeth II
est en train un petit peu de rebooster
non économie qui en tout cas pour
l'instant toi tu trouves énormément
parce que il y a une partie aussi une
grosse partie de la population Cyril qui
est conscient que c'est le souffle de
l'histoire qui est en train de parler
c'est complètement uniquement fou mais
est-ce que tu t'imagines tu vas devenir
un cardiologue un truc
je crois non
il est pas trop de son parti
il est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
qui a inventé ce métier celui de Harry
Potter quand même qui était au pouvoir
non mais c'est une expression populaire
ce qu'il a dit c'est à dire c'est pas
faut pas le prendre au premier degrés
c'est pas très digne c'est vrai
10 jours de deuil et de recueillement
après qu'est-ce qu'il veut mais non mais
les laisser le jazz calmer là je vais te
prendre un massage
et c'est comme si nous demain qui fait
la reine c'est comme si moi demain René
la Taupe passé l'arme à gauche
Bertrand 10 jours de recueillement
écoute le franchement
[Rires]
non quoi on a des vrais problèmes la
crise de l'énergie les prix des aliments
qui flanquent et on nous soule avec la
reine moi je te dis on en peut plus une
question est-ce que tu aurais été plus
triste si euh voilà je sais pas la pizza
reine avait disparu
bien sûr
retourne coronavirus à la guerre en
Ukraine a Vladimir Poutine je ne
l'accorde vas-y vas-y sans mémoire moi
je kiffais un peu la reine mais si je la
connais pas mais c'est vrai que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il a dit bouffer ça fait un
tollé pas possible est-ce que ça mérité
un tel tolé je vous pose la question que
vous pose la question mon Bertrand je
suis dans ton livre oui tu es dans mon
livre il paraît que tu dis des belles
choses sur moi
je sais mon bébé t'inquiète pas est-ce
que j'ai l'air inquiet
je suis pas inquiète pourquoi tu es
vénère parce que parce que voilà même
toi en gros tu dis bah non dans le fond
Mulhouse
[Rires]
est-ce que moi tu m'aimes contrairement
à Gilles moi tu m'aimes sur Siri
dans le livre maintenant mais pas du
tout
c'est bien sérieux on est comme ça je
t'explique je vois on parle courant tout
ça on a fait la galette des rois
ensemble
mais tu sais Cyril en quelque sorte que
je suis convaincu à vraiment que tu es
pour quelque chose dans cette histoire
parce que tu sais quand même que les
chiffres que tu fais sont pas mauvais du
tout ils sont même très très bons en
matière de dimath et que je suis quand
même venu très très régulièrement
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon ami c'est mon ami vas-y vas-y
c'est mieux vos amis
[Musique]
bravo
Bertrand va
demander aussi régulièrement de venir
donner des nouvelles de la reine c'est
que Cyril à moi que je sois bête
médiatique chose que l'on est en train
de voir dans les médias actuellement il
a totalement raison Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est un homme politique qui se veut
proche du peuple donc son but c'est
d'être proche des préoccupations des
Français donc quand il dit qu'on va se
bouffer de la reine pendant 10 jours ce
qui se dit c'est qu'en la couverture
médiatique et à l'ouest cet événement il
y a un décalage complet avec
ce que moi je pars demain à Mikono je
vais bouffer de la race
et la rentrée c'est l'inflation et il y
a plein de gens qui s'en fout
complètement regardez les audiences télé
bertrandisez oui peut-être un million de
personnes peut-être 2 millions de
personnes mais là majorité des gens ils
sont fous il a raison
oui c'est ce que j'allais dire c'est pas
juste sur le fond qu'on parle c'est sur
la forme comment il emploie
on s'en fout pas de la forme c'est un
politique donc si vous êtes des
politiques et vous de vous et votre vie
alors
parce qu'il est connu pour ça il va pas
changer Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce que je
peux parler s'il vous plaît Cyril
Hanouna
quand vous expliquer
comme ça qui doit rester comme ça moi je
trouve qu'il manque de respect justement
à son peuple parce que c'est pas parce
que le peuple
parle comme ça dans sa cuisine qu'il
faut s'adresser comme ça
pour moi pour moi vous êtes à l'ancienne
pour moi vous êtes à l'ancienne et c'est
parce que veulent les Français
aujourd'hui ils veulent ils veulent pas
du tout alors parle pas mal vous dites
alors vous dites non vous êtes à côté
mais les Français combien de fois il y a
de Français qui m'ont dit on va en
bouffer de la réponse Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il parle comme les
Français c'est pour ça qu'il a gagné
vous dites ça et en même temps quand on
quand il s'exprime comme ça il y en a
qui disent bah ça rabaisse la fonction
alors il faudrait savoir soit ça
rabaisse
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est son style il
changera jamais
c'est où vous l'aimez vous l'aimez pas
c'est comme la télé si vous n'aimez pas
quelqu'un vous zappez si vous n'aimez
pas vos dépôts pour lui voilà moi qui
n'aime pas par exemple excusez-moi il
fait du Jean-Luc Mélenchon exactement il
est colérique il est tumultueux il adore
faire des sorties comme ça il a la Fête
de l'Huma il est assis comme ah oui il
veut que la foule l'applaudisse la foule
est à sa cause voilà alors moi je suis
pas choquée quand il dit ça je suis
beaucoup quand il dit que la police tue
ça je trouve que c'est un digne voilà
voilà
il a il a un peu énormément parce qu'en
fait à force d'en avoir parlé de la
reine on est en train de la lâcher
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que il va
encore bouffer de la reine d'Angleterre
parce que jusqu'à
4 milliards de téléspectateurs vont être
devant leur petite écran
de ce soir on connaît déjà le nom de
code golden Horse c'est le nom de code
du couronnement du roi Charles troll
donne c'est à dire absolument c'est un
nombre de codes militaires qui a été
donné au prochain couronnement donc ce
qui veut dire que à Londres ils sont
déjà aussi en train de se pencher juste
après sur le couronnement du roi qui va
faire exactement le même raz-de-marée
qu'est-ce que vous diriez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce soir je n'ai rien à dire
monsieur mélange il y a tellement
d'autres personnes à qui je voudrais
parler de Jean-Luc Mélenchon un Jean-Luc
Mélenchon apparemment on va bouffer de
l'ail encore pendant 10 jours
encore pendant 10 jours Jean-Luc
qu'est-ce que vous vouliez diriez-vous
diriez quoi c'est un manque de respect
c'est pas vraiment oui c'est pas vous
avez raison dans ce que vous dites voilà
ça correspond au personnage je suis tout
à fait chaud voilà voilà moi
personnellement voilà peut-être que j'en
peux plus d'éducation que certaines
autres personnes en tout cas voilà je
suis un peu choqué par un en voilà un
manque de dignité je voudrais simplement
qu'on reconnaisse qu'on enterre
quelqu'un qui était pas comme les autres
et cela dit on reconnaisse quand même ah
oui bah on l'a dit bah on l'a dit je me
suis dit il faut apprendre
[Rires]
bisous
il a mis le doigt sur quelque chose et
qu'il avait dit différemment il avait
pas utilisé cette expression que moi je
ne cautionne pas sur la forme mais s'il
avait dit différemment on en aurait pas
parlé et en fait c'est un vrai sujet
le décès de la reine et pour qui j'ai
tout le respect du monde pour faire
diversion à ce sujet et ça c'est un vrai
problème de fond voilà vous adorez-la
non non non absolument pas tout à fait
pour le coup ce que l'on est en train de
connaître aujourd'hui Béatrice a fait 70
ans qu'on le répète rien n'a changé
depuis 70 ans ça fait le monde
a changé monsieur le monde a changé
dimanche ma mère a regardé alors ma mère
adore ça elle a regardé de 11h du matin
à 18h une voiture qui roule par un drone
juste une voiture qui roule avec un
cercueil pour le respect du monde pour
la reine mais à un moment donné il y a
peut-être aussi d'autres informations
dans le pays
il a zappé de vandalfort
on l'a fait pour Johnny Hallyday on l'a
fait pour Michael Jackson on l'a fait
pour plein de trucs
très partagé très partagé je voulais
juste peut-être dire une toute petite
parenthèse que j'avais commencé
peut-être elle n'a jamais fait d'entor
son 70 ans de règne
je disais et ça concerne la France c'est
pour ça que je le dis en 2002 donc il y
a Jacques Chirac qui est opposé au
deuxième tour à Jean-Marie Le Pen et
elle il y a une réception avec une gamme
Palace elle va trouver personnellement
le correspondant du Monde et à lui dire
i love very very j'aime beaucoup
Monsieur Chirac comment l'a dit le monde
j'aime beaucoup i love very very Jack
Chirac donc le monde le lendemain
il va y avoir un impact il va y avoir un
impact donc elle aimait intensément la
France c'était une grande francophile
aussi elle était probablement elle a
jamais eu l'entorse
tu es magnifique toi ça va oui ça va tu
connais L'Amour est dans le pré
tu aimes bien ça va
sur ton t-shirt
vous lui avez mis des tatouages partout
non mais c'est bien bête c'est bien
alors quoi alors c'est quoi disons que
elle a traversé son époque comme
personne elle s'est adaptée comme
personne on rappelle que quand elle
accède au trône seul 4 caméras de la BBC
sont autorisées sous les fautes de Will
Smither et là on a appris son décès par
8 c'est dommage là c'est par 8 par
une suite argentée
c'est montrer que c'est quelqu'un qui a
su s'adapter qui a su faire rentrer une
institution millénaire on rappelle que
le trône d'Angleterre la couronne
d'Angleterre a plus de 1000 ans dans le
monde actuel dans une maladie 2.0
ça je sais pas du tout pourquoi mais ce
que l'on peut dire et ben c'est que le
nouveau roi Charles III il a une passion
il a envie d'y aller c'est quoi sa
passion nouveau roi Charles III il
collectionne les lunettes de toilette
un peu particulier
suis encore dans la près dans Elisabeth
II mais je voulais dire je vais faire
comme si j'avais pas entendu la question
tu kiffais les DJ non non
parce que moi voilà moi je suis pro
Élisabeth II je suis pro défenseur de la
couronne je crois en cette institution
et Lady c'était quand même tout le
contraire elle a fait tout ce qui était
question
elle a su s'adapter elle pour le coup
Camille aussi et je sais pas c'était la
maîtresse du prince Charles quand il
était avec de Lili ce qui est
merveilleux donc Camilla c'est que avec
ce mariage qui a eu lieu en 2005 et bah
Camilla elle a vengé
on la sortait en Irlande aujourd'hui
était depuis le 6 juin dernier date où
je vous ai dit j'étais ici pour vous
faire vivre le jubilé depuis le 6 juin
elle n'est plus rentrée avec une gamme à
partir de demain la dépouille quitte le
palais pour Westminster Hall et alors en
4 jours 24 heures sur 24 de
recueillement on estime déjà aujourd'hui
à 35 heures la file d'attente qu'il y a
pour venir se recueillir devant la reine
Élisabeth II et lundi obsèques
solennelle en l'abbaye de twitchester
bien sûr hein
mon bébé là il m'a dit je sais il
m'adore vous savez pas vous comment il
kiffe hein bébé c'est touché tout comme
ça là tu prends la mouche pour un oui
pour un an il y a peut-être que je mange
est-ce que tu travailles parce que c'est
pour moi quand même
vécu tout ça quand même voilà qui
allez t'inquiète pas on est là et tu
sais qu'on te soutient voilà bah oui mon
bébé